oh so let's put this on the table
speaking of naive
i still more than the two of you by far
i think have faith that government can
work
okay let's put that on the wait i gotta
i'm not trying to be pedantic what do
you mean
work government can't achieve goals that
is not in dispute you can achieve
goals effectively to build a better
world
okay a a functioning society so i'm
gonna take it one step
further than you oh boy the only way to
achieve a better world
is through government michael what do
you think about that he almost dropped
and i said it on purpose that way no i i
i in
dropping you cannot you cannot achieve
you cannot have
liberty or freedom without a government
now
not anything like the governments we
have today so i think i think the
idea that you can have liberty of
freedom without
government is the rejection of the idea
of liberty and freedom
um and and the undermining of any effort
any attempt to do it so in that sense i
don't know who's sitting here right lex
i know exactly on this side we can agree
with lex yeah it's unusual that
government is good for freedom agreement
with the guy who's reading minecon
that's not a surprise he's dressed in
black yeah that's the bad guys
no the the the the the fascism
i mean the road to fascism is anarchy
it's not
what the hell are you talking about and
i think what exactly when anarchy led to
fascism
well every example of a stateless
society leads to authoritarianism every
single one in all of human history and
well
it has to because you're saying why
heart germany was uh
anarchy well it was it wasn't pioneer
but it got close but no
i didn't say i said the reverse by the
way i said the reverse i didn't say that
every form of authoritarianism
started with anarchy i said that every
situation in which human beings lived
under anarchy
led to authoritarianism so i said to
flip
anarchism isn't a location anarchism is
a relationship
the three of us are in an anarchist
relationship every country is
in a relationship of anarchy toward each
other the u.s and canada have an
anarchist relationship toward one
another
and to claim you know when
going back to emma goldman who i love
in 1901 uh william mckinley president
mckinley was shot by this guy leon
salgaz
and it was very funny he was a crazy
person
and they arrested him he shot the
president and they go why did you shoot
president mckinley and he just goes i
was radicalized by emma goldman and
she's like oh god
so now she's on the lamb she had nothing
to do with this guy she's trying to flee
she gets arrested they caught her and
she said and this is the the hubris of
this woman which i admire
as the subject of you good hubris she
goes i'd like to thank the cops
for doing what they're doing they're
turning far more people into anarchism
than i could do
on my own so given everything you've
said in these
two hours and then to pivot to
uh being anti-government is being
anti-liberty i don't feel i have to say
anything
well okay for people who are not
familiar if you're i don't know
why you would not be familiar but uh
michael malus
talks quite a bit about the evils of the
state and government
and espouses ideas that uh anarchism
is actually what is it the most moral
system the most effective system for
human relationships
there's this great book called atlas
shrugged and the
author posits in anarchist private
society she calls it galt sculch
where everything is privately owned and
everyone is no one is in a position of
authority
over anyone else other than the
landowner that's an anarchist society
there's
one judge yeah and one authority yeah
and that's what everybody hold on and
that's what everyone and that's what
everyone has voluntarily
moved there and agreed to be under it's
a very small community right sure
that is right so i have no problem with
competing governments
that's the definition of anarchism
what's that that's the definition of
anarchism case claims okay end the show
and the show i got him i got him over
i'm all for competing governments get
more cookies good job
he did it he did it yeah yeah wrong you
brought him over
lithuanian
competing governments on different
geographic areas
uh that that's that's fine why does it
have to be
okay let me uh it's it's really crucial
that that it's on different
so you don't have two uh judges in gold
sculpture you have one
and and there's a reason one there's one
authority there's one system
of laws in gold's gulch uh that
that is that all the people under the
gulch abide by there's one there's two
because they're
they're in america no they're not the
whole point is they're not right
they're not in america they're in
colorado i know but but the whole point
of the novel is they've left
america they haven't left america
they've they've hit themselves so
they're not under the authority of
america but they are
don't think they're not but they're
hidden and they're supposed to be the
point is that they're hidden so they're
not under
if you if the three of us hide we're
still under the authority of washington
no but not if they don't but this is why
they haven't established the state and
it's not
it's not a government and it's not in
that sense com
you know an example
of of of really the way we form
societies
it is a private club that is hidden away
from everybody else fine
i'm fine with that what happens if an
american kills a canadian in mexico
what happens in american it depends
depends on the nature of the governments
of the three places
right but usually what happens in most
of human history
is that america will launch a war either
against mexico or canada
okay just first of all so usually
violence results in much more violence
anarchy is just a system that legalizes
violence that's all it does and in
international affairs
that's the reality the reality is that
the way you resolve disputes
that are major disputes is through
violence ein rand said
the definition of a government is an
agency that has a monopoly of force in a
geographical area
so you can't complain that anarchism is
legalizing violence when the definition
of government according to rand is
legalized violence
no but because you you're taking the
definition of violence the way she
defines it right in this context
a she talks about retaliatory force only
and has that ever happened
that's not the point that is the point
before there was aristotle was in
aristotle before there was an america
was in america
the fact that something has never
existed means that it will never exist
before
the fact that the ideas haven't been
developed to make something exist means
that it will never exist before
you know where young human race is a
young race the ideas of freedom are very
young
the ideas of the enlightenment are just
250 years old the idea that you can't
create
the kind of government i talked about i
talk about that
that it's never been before means it
will never happen again that's a silly
argument it's not a silly argument it's
you're being a platonist
no not at all i'll explain to you how
you're being exactly a platoonist
so if i was sitting in 1750 arguing with
thomas jefferson he was telling me what
kind of state he was going to
create and i said is a state like this
ever been created and he said no was i
being a plaintiff
of course not no you know things change
you're being a politeness now
here's why you're being a politeness now
because one of the
things that aristotle believed in one of
the things that ayn rand and other
contexts believed in
the cover of her book the uh philosophy
who needs it
is i think it's the sistine chapel the
cover or wherever it is it's aristotle
and
plato walking no not yeah but what's
that painting i forget what it is
it's the school of athens school of
athletes thank
plato's pointing toward the heavens
while they're talking and
aristotle's pointing to the earth
reality reality absolutely
so if you want there's two approaches
there's the descartes cartesian
approach which is i sit in my armchair
and i deduce
all of reality or if i want to study the
nature of man
if i want to study the nature of dogs if
it wants the nature of the sun
i have to look around i have to open my
eyes i have to look at data
it's very difficult you know when rand
was on donahue
he asked her about aren't you impressed
with the order in the universe and she
goes oh
now you have to give me a moment and the
point she made which was
very hard for many people to grasp is
hard for me to grasp is
one's concept of order comes from the
universe
you can't have a disorderly universe
because order means
describing that which exists and which
has existed
now if you are looking at
governments throughout history that have
always existed and
when you were on lex you said what i'm
talking about
has never existed that's right to say
that this
therefore that that has a possibility of
working in reality
i think is uh certainly not a point in
that favor number one
and number two jefferson was a fraud
what jefferson argued how america would
look
did not come true jefferson's concerns
about the constitution
were accurate and the fact is the
federal government did become
centralized
did become a civil war so if you tell mr
jefferson
the government you're positing can't
work you would have been correct
that's not what i'm saying it's not the
issue of can it work or not
it's the issue of can something exist
that hasn't existed in the past
it's a it's a it's a silly argument now
we can argue about the facts of reality
whether such a thing can exist
but to say it hasn't existed in the past
is not an argument about whether it can
exist in the future
but that's argument you made no no
you're talking about history and now
you're dancing around it no i'm not yes
you are i'm saying i'm saying that
something different happened in the
founding of america it might not have
been perfect
might not be an ideal it might have been
some people even think it was bad right
sure but something different happened
sure
and you could have sat 20 years before
and said well that's never happened
before so it can't happen in the future
that is a that is a bad argument it's
not a good argument
it is irrelevant no but you're making
the argument because something hasn't
happened before
does that's certainly not a point to say
it's likely to happen or possible
no i'm saying i'm saying first of all i
i agree that everything we know about
what's possible or what's not possible
has to be from reality that we agree
completely i think i think anarchists
completely evade that point i think you
guys
live in a world of of uh mythology of
abstraction of the cart
to imagine the kind of anarchy that
david friedman or
or rothbard described it's complete
fiction and it's complete
that's just name called mysticism okay
let me ask just a few dumb questions so
so first of all uh what do we do with
violence
uh in terms of just natural emergence of
violence in human societies
sure so the idea that anarchism proposes
is that we would as the community grows
there may be violence and then we
together
form collectives that sort of fund
mechanisms that resist that violence
i mean that's i'd love to sort of talk
about violence because that seems to be
the
the core thing that's the difference
between the state
that has a was definitionally i guess is
the thing that
has a monopoly on violence or
controls violence in such a way that you
don't have to worry about it and then
the anarchism
i don't know because i'm using bad words
no your definition is accurate but
the point is that being the definition
of the state versus how states
act reality is just absurd yeah so uh
and and then the idea that anarchism
would be is that it's more kind of
a market of uh defenses against
violence so you you have like security
companies and then you hire different
ones that you have more competences
you have things being made affordable
you have more accessibility
to security you have accountability when
people misuse their power
and you have uh more layers of security
than having a government monopoly
objectivists understand and they don't
deny this this is something they talk
about constantly
is anytime you have a government
monopoly it's going to
have enormous distortions as a
consequence it's going to be expensive
it's going to be ineffective and when
you're talking about ineffectiveness
in markets that's not just you know like
the cup sucks it often means
mass death it often means persecution so
this is something that anarchism uh um
if not entirely prevents certainly
mitigates enormously so can i just as a
thought experiment
say it was very easy to immigrate to
another country like where you could
just move about
from government to government sure would
that alleviate most of the problems that
you have
towards the state which is like people
being free to choose which government
they
operate under wouldn't that essentially
yeah
so like what is i i'm trying to
understand why
governments aren't already the thing
that's the goal of anarchism
the kind of collectives that emerge
under anarchism it seems to be what
government
you're equating two terms yeah so
there's something called like private
governance
and there's government so for example if
i go to
jaron's house and he has a rule take off
your shoes become your house
if you want to really be kind of silly
about it you could say he's the governor
it's this
but it's it's it's really nonsensical to
say that if you go to macy's
right if you want to return your sweater
macy's rules are right up there
you have seven days if you don't have a
receipt you're going to get store credit
if you do ever see
you get a refund so every organization
every bar
every night club your house has rules of
governments this is
it's often they're unspoken this is
unavoidable no one in america
uh by law has to pay a tip
but it's just customary you go with the
waiter you give them 15 20
so on and so forth now what anarchism
does
is it says okay security is something
that
is of crucial essential human need
we all need to be safe in our property
safe in our purpose
the organization that by far is the
biggest violator of this
and always has been always will be is
the government why
because it's a monopoly because it has
no accountability and
look at the writing last year right if
you have one agency
pretend it's not the government pretend
it's apple and apple has the ch
in charge of security in this town
people are lied riding people looting
and apple says yeah we're not going to
send people into work and if you try to
defend yourself
we're going to put you in jail as well
that's the problem of having a
government monopoly
and that's something that anarchism
solves for so okay but
don't you because you said no
accountability don't you mean to say
poor accountability no i mean to say no
accountability i mean but isn't that the
idea of
democracies not for democracy no not for
democracy but like the system of
of governments that we have uh there is
a monopoly on violence
but there is a uh i mean at least in the
ideal but i think in practice as well
there's an
accountability i might not think i know
you're a critic of the police force and
all those kinds of things but
the military is accountable to the
people i do not the police forces
accountable
in perhaps imperfectly but you're saying
not at all not at all and we've seen
many examples of police officers
doing horrific things on video and they
don't even lose their power but there's
a lot of amazing police officers no
you i mean no they're not so you're
saying by nature
police is like a fundamentally flawed no
by nature government monopoly and police
is a fundamentally
irredeemable system we'll talk about
private security
if i have a private security firm you
could have that with under a government
and as a result of my private security
my person who i'm bodyguarding
gets shot that's going to be very bad
for my company
as compared to competing companies
however when you have a government
monopoly and i get people shot
what are you going to do so so
the problem is that all the examples are
going to be within the context of an
existing government this is why i said
the cell phone example and all these
other examples of us being here we're
not in anarchy
that is absurd we're under a particular
system of law and the system of laws
applies and we know
that this is a particular system of laws
applies so the problem is when you have
uh there are many laws that we're not
going to be enforced
that we're not sure we know that
violence related no there are lots of
laws that are not going to be enforced
right and and and uh that
that doesn't make this anarchy because
there are the laws out there they could
be enforced
which makes which makes an enormous
business but look there's a there's a
number of issues here
uh there's an issue of the role of force
in in in
i got to clarify thing because i think
you misunderstood what i said i i'm not
saying that
america is anarchist what i'm saying is
the three of us have an anarchist
relationship between us
because none of us have authority over
the others that's what i'm saying but
but that is a that's a bad use of the
word anarchy no that's the correct use
the word anarchy
it makes it meaningless it makes it
every time any people get together they
have an anarchistic relationship yes
no we have a voluntary relationship
that's what anarchism means
terrorism no it doesn't it's it's it's
it's it's a political way to get a
dictionary out
you're taking a word and it's accepted
usage and then you
you're saying oh no it means selfishness
maybe and we never finished that
discussion
you're taking a word we're taking a word
that that you're defining
as as and replacing it with volunteering
now
i'm not for energy it's not volatilism
but let me let's let's understand what
volunteering
means right so we for example go into
stores and and there's a certain
relationship that we have with the store
that we engage in certain voluntary
transactions with testo
now i believe that that works because
there is a certain system of law that
both the store and we have accepted
that makes that possible now if that
didn't
there are certain people would like to
walk into the store and just take the
stuff
right so there is a not we might not
but there are certain people who might
want it to go into their store there's a
certain system of laws that regulates
the relationship and and that defines
the property rights
and then provides protection for the
property rights now you would like all
that privatized
that is the store would have its police
force and they that would be privatized
now i don't believe that
force can be privatized um and the ru
and there are many reasons i don't think
he can
and i don't think i i think i think it's
an interesting distinction
i i don't think it can because i think
that it's an unstable equilibrium
right i don't think competing uh uh
police forces can work
uh the at the end the police votes with
the biggest gun
always wins and always takes over that's
true and because
look at iran and iraq excuse me we had
the bigger guns we didn't win
look at afghanistan we didn't
we didn't win partially because none of
that is an example of anarchy no but you
said you just said the guy with the
biggest guns gonna win yeah the guy with
the biggest gun we didn't win in vietnam
we had the bigger guns but again you're
taking it outside of a context
that was a context in which uh there was
a context which countries are fighting
not a contract
in which there is no okay ron have a
rocket launcher yes
and there's a hundred people with
handguns how are you gonna win you have
the biggest gun
oh believe me i could win with one
rocket launcher against 100 people
yeah it's just it's a good well depends
how many rockets i have in the rocket
launcher and
whether i'm willing to use them but
that's but so so now it's democracy
because they're more of them that they
win
look the the any one of these scenarios
all it does
so so let's go back to the store so this
is fascinating by the way i'm really
enjoying this i just want to say that
this is great because i'm glad you are
i am enjoying the pain and i'm also
enjoying the comments that are going to
happen
oh the comments the comments could be
overwhelmingly on your side
i don't know i think so no i think the
anarchy position is completely dishonest
i'm a modern day what's his name
what's the guy who is defending
communism oh rachel
i'm a monday richard wolfe there's a
sense in which i think anarchists
are uh evading reality in the same sense
you know so so we've got this i think
i'm dishonest or delusional
i think calling someone dishonest is a
really
and as i said on the show on the
previous uh interview i said
only smart people can be anarchists
because it requires a certain level of
abstraction of
divorce being divorced from reality that
is hard for people who are actually
connected to reality he makes a good
point because i always talk about this
with people on social media and they
talk about a lot of people who buy into
the corporate
media narrative and how they're dumb i
go it's easier to train smart people
than dumb people
it's easy to convince smart people of
the systemic that's the voice from
reality when somebody's done yeah
yeah with the concretes that actually
happen
um this is an example i gave uh
debating another anarchist so who was it
it must have sucked
uh well you were the only happy fans
the people i like the least um in the
world out there
uh you know you like them better than
the communists don't you
barely oh come on seriously yes because
i think it leaves the same place i
really do i think it leads to gulags
fine i think anarchy leaves the ghoul
and i think hopper's view of anarchy
definitely leaks to go look i'll i'll
grant you just for the sake of argument
that it leads to gulags
however surely you concede that they
are against gulags whereas the commies
have no problem with it and that's a big
i think some do i'm not sure i'm not
your people i hope they do because if
you if you read
if you read some of his stuff one
wonders right uh
you know but wants monarchies and he
wants uh once uh he said monarchies are
preferable to democracy
which is true no it's not oh god i mean
one of the problems with anarchists is
what judge that's the most
one of the problems yeah one judge one
authority this is why
that's why i think although it
i don't want a an arbitrary judge i want
an objective judge
there's an essay by john hasn't has to
think his name i'm going to bungle it
it's going to be in my upcoming book on
anarchism
and he just discusses and it's a very
long complicated technical issue
that the idea of objective law is
incoherent
well yeah i mean that's why we disagree
so much yeah because
because i think objective laws the only
coherences do you disagree
that we in effect have competing
uh systems of law under america meaning
there's different ideologies
uh you have the sotomayor ideology
versus the scalia ideology
and that effectively and the point being
when you and i file a lawsuit
it completely depends on who the judge
is yes and in theory
in theory i don't think the system works
this way but in theory the way the
system would work
is that on new issues there are there is
some competition nice to meet you
syria wasn't talking technology
capitalism say in theory the system
works
and this works i think i think with
competing states but also
with competing legal idea views
particularly on a new issue
there's some uh this is how common law
it worked right there's some evolution
of it and at some point
that gets codified into the law and it
gets objectified in that sense that is
there's some conclusion
that people come to this is the role in
theory of a legislation the legislation
would be nice it was
if it was composed of people who uh had
some idea of legal philosophy sure
uh and and it gets codified and when it
because these things are complex
and and at some point it goes through
all the arguments and then
a certain truth emerges or certainly is
identified and that's what gets encoded
in law
that's what the purpose of the
legislature is now if you have competing
mechanisms that don't converge on one
authority because there's no one
authority
there are multiple authorities that is
in a sense say multiple governments or
multiple
uh systems of enforcement right then you
get
not just something emerging out of it
what you get is competing legal systems
competing legal systems that now have
competing
mechanisms of enforcement competing
police forces completing
militaries however we wanted to find it
and now there's no mechanism to resolve
that
now yes we could negotiate and there's
good
will and so on right yeah no there you
go no
but but now we're talking about the law
what each view
each position views as true and right
right and it might involve for example
it might involve the fact that the legal
system has come to the conclusion that
it's okay for children to have sex
with adults and this legal system thinks
that is
evil and wrong sure right and uh you
know this
something has happened right between the
two right how do you resolve that
conflict
there is no resolution you know this
adult wants to have sex with this child
this legal system thinks it's okay that
the system thinks the only way to
resolve that system is through one
system imposing itself on the other
an example of countries is exactly that
when you had monarchies
when you had little states all over the
place the way
any kind of dispute was resolved when
there were issues of territorial
disputes
or issues of marriage or service of of
different legal interpretations about
was whoa no yes it was marriage a lot of
times people would marry a princess from
another country sure
forced marriages which was not very
pleasant i'd rather sacrifice one
princess than a car no i don't want to
sacrifice anybody
and in addition i don't know i want to
sacrifice the role and in addition
well i don't want royals well that's
what i think those are pretty disgusting
and then on top of that you look those
periods in history are filled with
violence
much more violence than we have today
much more bloody than they are today
far less freedom than we have today
comparing this to the 20th century
yes i'm comparing a monarchy right you
you
you cho you said that's preferable to
democracy yes right
yeah i'm comparing i think hapa said
that i'm not saying i'm saying that oh i
thought you
agreed and i think it's ridiculous
these kings and queens were fighting
constantly i mean the wars
back then were violent in a way unlike
now
no much more violent okay now if you
look at the actual percentage of people
killed
the sagas of of iceland about how
wonderful the anarchy and
i mean it's funny because a lot of
people who read they're feminine never
read the sagas
it's worth reading uh the sagas of the
sagas of the iceland are filled
with violence constant violence
constantly people killing each other
over i you know i stole your chickens
and you slept with my wife and uh
the only way to resolve disputes the
only way to resolve the streets
was violence there was no authority
there was no mechanism to resolve
these disputes there was a council but
the council couldn't enforce anything so
in the end of the day we just resolved
to violence
and this is legalized because there is
no
there is no mechanism by which to make
the violence illegal
so all anarchy is is legalized violence
constrained
constrained up you know uh
for a while and up until people
stop that constraint by you know
arrangements between
the uh security organizations but the
security conditions have us by the balls
to put it figuratively right they really
do
sure unlike the state oh the state today
has it but i would much rather live in
this state much rather live in the state
much rather live in many
more authoritarian states than this than
a place
where there's constant violence i have a
bunch of questions but i'm enjoying this
why everything he said is wrong
okay yes first of all the idea of
competing legal systems
is inevitable because uh what rand
talked about
is what she wanted was and this is
really kind of eric out of character
with her broader ideology is
i think this was her term and i'm not
saying this to make fun of you when she
has a judge
and he's looking at the information she
wants him to be basically i think she's
the word robot
someone without any ideology that
they're just looking at the facts
they're not bringing their
kind of world view to it i take it as a
compliment you
are welcome i think that
given otherwise her correct
view that ideology causing the ideology
is just a slur for someone's philosophy
that someone especially
someone is erudite educated and informed
as a judge
has to and in fact should bring their
ideology to their work
is in one sensible contradiction in her
view number one
number two is we have right now the d.a
in san francisco uh i i forget his name
he's the son of literal terrorists
communist terrorists
and he has made it the decree
unilaterally
that if you shoplift for less than i
forget two hundred dollars
we're not prosecuted you know this game
right right
so now you and i
certainly and lex i'm sure probably
agree that his ideology is abhorrent
that this doesn't help poor people it
doesn't help shop owners
it creates a culture an area
where it's just deleterious to human
life however
he has in one sense given that he is a
state operative a legitimate
world view can i ask you just a quick
question sure why couldn't a security
force
in a particular in a particular context
say yeah if you
if you take if you take stuff on that
store we're not going to we
we're not going to have that i agree
with you that's very fair that's that's
a very legitimate question the point is
in the context that i'm talking about
that firm
is like wait a minute i'm hiring you for
security you're saying we're not going
to provide security
why am i writing you a check and we have
examples of this in real life
if i get into a car accident with you
right
you have your car insurance i have my
car insurance
if your car insurance had their druthers
they wouldn't pay me one penny
if my car insurance didn't have their
druthers they wouldn't pay you one penny
we already have all you were saying
earlier that we need to have one kind of
umbrella mechanical fuse
there are already more cases than you
can count where there's private
uh um arbitration now the argument is
the private arbitration only works
because they have recourse to the
government but my point is
there's many examples where even though
that recourse is theoretically possible
it's not a realistic concern
specifically because
they know that if you have recourse to
the state
you have no concept of what that outcome
is going to look like
except knowing it's going to be
exorbitant
it's going to be time-consuming uh talk
about that
we can't use the state right i mean i'm
as critical as the state as it is right
now
maybe not as critical as yours not as
critical but i'm quite critical of the
state as it is right now
um but but let's say let's say we got
into a traffic accident
and uh you you have a rolls voice um and
and i destroyed your world's voice and
my insurance company now owes your
insurance company a lot of money
and and let's imagine it's a lot of
money just for the city and that you're
clearly guilty
yeah clearly guilty and my insurance
company looks at the books and it goes
you know i don't
really i don't want to pay this sure i
and and you know what i've got bigger
guns than his insurance company
sure and i'm going to just going to take
over their insurance company and and
hostile takeover takes on a whole new
meaning
when when i can i can muster guns on my
behalf
than than in in a hostile takeover in a
capitalist
context um that to me is what happens
that to me is inevitable
lee what happens and it's and i think
this is where the delusion comes in
the idea that everything that that when
big money is involved and big and power
is involved
remember again the same kind of
politicians who today
get into politics are likely to want to
run some of these security agencies
because they'll have a lot of power over
people
uh so same kind of uh uh maybe social
passwords i don't think it's the same
skill set but that's a separate issue i
i think it very much is
uh but you think people the people in
washington the same the ceos
psychologically and skill set wise
well today ceos yes okay yes
because they might be right because i
think that's what's rewarded for ceo
somebody who could get along with with
government and i think and i think the
kind of ceo
who is going to run a security company
which is not just about business
it's about the use of force it's about
control it's about negotiation with
other entities that are using force
negotiate you know
diploma diplomacy then negate and and we
should get back to
objective law because i think it's
essential something
i think all you get into is security
agencies fighting security agencies and
again the biggest gun
and it and i don't mean here the guy who
has the biggest literal gun the rocket
launcher versus the guns i got excited
by the biggest gun yeah the party that
has the more
physical force however that is mustered
either by numbers
sure or by weapons is going to dominate
can i can i and we'll take over
everybody else now one of the things
that's
common in a market is takeovers it's
it's it's consolidation and here
the consolidation can happen through
force and it can you can roll other
other security companies and that's
exactly what will happen until you
dominate
the particular geographic area okay so
let me explain why i disagree with that
you were just saying and i agree
correctly i agree with you that
listen if i have access to the bigger
gun why am i paying you or whoever's
paying wherever
i'm just going to use force and not pay
them we have that right now it's called
lobbying
yeah so instead instead of me and i
i'm sure in your example you weren't
being literal instead of the insurance
company literally having
the army they could be like hey let me
call corruptco with the mafia i agree
yeah go out and take them out
by having this federal government as you
know and certainly
are not a fan of has takes more through
um ask the forfeiture then burglaries
combined
what assets forfeiture is people don't
even understand this this is something
crazy which i'm you which are on
it's as opposed to me as a post as i am
which is
i'm a cop i go to your house i
think you haven't been charged or or
convicted of anything
i i have evidence usually in a car yeah
yeah but no it's like drug deals
okay i go to your house you're a drug
dealer i
say and you can understand the reasoning
well if someone is getting profit
through illegal
mechanisms their profit isn't real their
property and they shouldn't be rewarded
that profit so basically
i go to your house you're a drug dealer
i seize all your property
you don't really have recourse even
though you haven't been through deep i'm
just explaining to the audience
through due process and sol
that combined for people who don't know
is more than the total amount of
burglaries in america
it's a huge ince and what happens is the
police department
which seizes your car auctions it sees
your house auctions it it's a great way
to
fly in their pockets this is a huge
incentive it's horrible
it's a huge incentive for police
departments
to do this because it's like look this
guy's a crook
maybe he's not a drug dealer but he's
clearly a pimp let me just take all his
stuff and it's going to go to the
community
well and the rationale originally was if
i try him
in the meantime he'll take that money
and you know funnel it somewhere else
and hide it and i'll never be able to
get access to it
and it was it was past the 1970s under
the original
seized laws were kind of rico act sure
going after the mafia
and one of the reasons i despise
giuliani as much as i do and there's
very few politicians out there that i
despise more
is because he he was the first guy to
use rico on financiers yeah
and so it wasn't even a drug dealer it
was you were accused of a financial
fraud not not you weren't shown to be
guilty
yeah basically what forfeiture
innocence are proven guilty if you were
managing money
you were done you were finished so
you're saying this kind of stuff
national emergency with the states
hold up so my point is what are
presented as the strongest criticisms of
anarchism
are inevitably descriptions of status
quo what you're describing
is already the event i am a big
insurance company
i don't want to pay you i call
washington
either i pay you in washington gives me
a subsidy so what you're describing
is an inevitable aspect of having a
government see
so what i'm describing is the inevitable
evolution of anarchy into a government i
just think that the
markets don't consolidate into monopoly
that's the leftist propaganda myth
not not markets not markets where you
have substitute products but this is the
problem
the problem is force has no substitute
that is force
is not a product you can have a so this
is my fundamental
issue about turning police competing
police forces
force is not a product first service
it's not a service
and it's not a security is not a service
no well security
security in the context of a legal
system is but this is the point
the legal system the laws are not a
service or product
they are a different type of human
institution
um science is not a product or service
it's a different type of human
institution they're different types of
human institutions
some a market you can create markets in
some you cannot
law is not a marketable uh system yeah
question quickly
is there any other field other than law
that you think you can't create markets
well science science is not marketable
the the science itself is not marketable
well sure
science is true and the same ethic is
indole law is not marketable
law is the system that allows markets to
happen
right you need a system of law whether
it's private law in a in a particular
narrow context or whether it's broader
law
law is this is the is the context in
which markets arise
so one of the reasons we transact is we
know that there's a certain contract
between us explicit or implicit
that is protected by a certain law
whether it's protected by private agency
or pri
the government doesn't matter but
there's a certain contract that is
protectable
right theoretically theoretically yes so
law is the context in which markets
arise
you don't create a market
in the because there's nothing above it
in a sense there's no
it is the it is the context that allows
markets to be created
once you market it markets fall apart
so you think that law could be a market
and it already is a market and we see it
for example ebay
if i am buying something from your own i
won't even know his name i don't know
maybe he's in
another country i and you know he screws
me out of the money
i don't have ax i can't sue you like or
if i sue you in england it's good luck
with that
you're not gonna argue that i'm gonna
sue you what happens in this case which
has already been solved by the market
ebay and paypal which has access to your
bank account they act as the private
arbiter they're gonna get it wrong a lot
not not even a question just like
euron's not gonna argue
that the the government right now gets
the wrong a lot that's not even a
question
the point is at the very least i'm going
to get my resolution faster
cheaper and more effectively so the
issue with
having any kind of government anything
and euron's not going to disagree with
this
is it at the very least it's going to be
expensive inefficient
and and cause uh uh conflict yeah but i
think what it allows
is we don't even know what the supreme
court is going to judge
again you're moving us to today's
environment which i which
i'm trying against no but in reality
reality doesn't have to be what it is i
mean
that's the most anti-rant quote no in in
a sense in a sense
in a sense of of the politics the i know
but the quote by itself is great i know
i know
you'd love to agree with donald hoffman
as well yeah yeah it turns out i agree
with her
so it's it's where were we so i believe
that because we have
a certain system of government right it
allows for these private innovations
to come about that facilitates certain
issues in a much more efficient way
than the government would deal with it
but it's only because we have
a particular system that has defined
property rights
that has a clear view of what property
rights are it has a clear view of what
a transaction mean or what the contra
what contract law is and
ebay has a bunch of stuff that you sign
whether you read it or not
all of that is defined first and then
there are massive innovations
at the at the level of particular
transactions at the level of an ebay
that facilitate increased efficiency and
that's great but the fact is none of
that gets developed
none of that gets created in a world in
which i might be living under different
definition of property rights
ebay might be living on a separate
definition of property rights you might
have a third definition of property
rights
and there's no mechanism by which we can
actually
operationalize that because we all have
a different system there is a mechanic
we already have that let's change the
example i just used what happens if a
chinese person who has different
definition proper rights kills in
america american
in brazil again in in in in a smaller
community
what happens is lots of violence no but
i'm talking right now if
a chinese person has right now the only
reason that that it doesn't lead to
violence
is because people are afraid of even
more violence and it affects
many people large numbers of people who
don't want to go to war
but if if you have if you have small
in a state where the states were small
like in in those little states
there was war all the time for exactly
those reasons because
the cost was lower because uh because it
was more personal
because i knew maybe the person who was
killed over there and i i went to my
king and encouraged them to go to war
you know why there was
constant you know why there was war
because there had been no
no iron rand and good ideas
lead to good societies which leads to
good people
which lead to good behavior good into
relationships so now that we have iran
yes all this stuff in the past is
irrelevant because if they studied her
works we would be
rand was on donahue again you can watch
the clip
and he asks her she goes he goes you're
saying
that if we were more selfish and acted
more self-interest
there'd be less war less hitler and she
said
there wouldn't be any right well if we
were all selfish there wouldn't be any
hitler's right but who do you regard as
the overwinning authority
if i am buying a product from you as a
someone in england via ebay who's the
governing authority
the governing authority is other legal
systems
in england in the united states which
have to be synchronized pretty well
right but what i'm saying why do they
have to why ebay doesn't function in
certain countries because there is no
legal system
why do those legal systems have to be a
function specifically of geography
as opposed to why can't i sitting here
right i could sit here you're not
let me finish my point i can sit here
and be a british diplomat
right and as a british diplomat i'm
going to be treated differently under
american law
than you are as an american citizen as
you are why can't you have that same
process sure we're geographically
proximate
but i'm a citizen of this company and
you're a citizen of that company
why would that be different in your
opinion be if it's england in the united
states
it's probably not going to matter that
much right but if it's
iran and the united states then the fact
that we're sitting next to each other
makes a huge difference oh i have a
massive difference
and the fact is that an iron man i think
would would be the first to acknowledge
this and this is why she was she was so
opposed to anarchy
it's not why it is it's because of
rothbard
no it has nothing to do with nothing it
has nothing to do with nothing
nothing how do you know nothing how
would you because the argument against
uh against anarchy as an intellectual
one not a personality can be both
anyway but back to it vector on back to
iran
you don't know that you're not a psychic
or a necromancer the only way we're
gonna resolve uh this
is unwrestling right it's to violence
our best thing is not violence
wars of violence words are violence of
violence
emotions of violence so wait but he
follows me off with this stuff
but that's the problem actually very
very good no not facts of truth i mean
there's distortions
and arbitrary statements because your
statement about rothbard is an arbitrary
statement that has no cognitive
standing and therefore i can dismiss it
so i'm not doing like this because i
wanna
it the fact that she disliked rothbard
doesn't mean that everything he said she
was going to dismiss because she
disliked i agree with you but what i'm
saying is it would not be impossible but
there's no evidence i'll give you i'll
talk i'll give you some evidence
human psychology it is not impossible
that if you hate some uh what's his name
what's that guy's name
right it's not impossible that if
richard wolff said something that you
would otherwise agree with
you hold on let me finish you'd be
dismissive or less likely to give him
credit for it
being a human being that's all i'm
saying it's as silly as to say rothbard
came up with this theory of anarchy
because he he he he was pissed off at
ein ran and wanted to
write something i don't know bring it
down because
bring it down so that he can speak too
and let's let's let's keep it
because i don't think we're getting
agitated no you guys aren't no no
yeah yeah yeah yeah no bringing it down
not in terms of
in terms of give more pauses okay so
okay michael can insert himself
that's what i mean the private
governance point of that private
government
um private he's look it's private
governance it's
trying to establish this geographic law
of the land
i i do think that michael's i mean
that's interesting that you disagree
with this i i do
believe that psychology has an impact on
ideas and iran
you don't think iron rand had grudges
that impacted
the way she saw the world i
i we would like to think that i don't
think any of the grudges entered into
philosophical statements at least not
that i can tell
um and i don't see and given the
centrality
iron man gave and if you to to the role
of government to the existence of
government the need for government
uh to establish real freedom uh and the
way she defines freedom which is very
different than rothbard
and the way she defines government um to
say
then that opposition anarchy is because
of
i i think is just just an obvious
statement because
it's not right and not and not and
and i don't see why psychology would
answer it now
maybe the tone in which you responded to
it to answer might have been motivated
by that something like
but given the amount of thought she gave
to the world of government and human
society and why government was needed
and why you needed laws in order to be
free that you that freedom didn't
proceed
the right you needed to write hierarchy
i you know i think
i think that i think that we could say
that it give it at least the respect
that
she this was she might have been wrong
right
but she she had a particular theory that
rejected anarchy
and the thought anarchy was wrong okay
hold on i res i i really resent
and i don't want saying you're doing
this the implication that
if rand was guided by her passions that
somehow is the criticism of her or
lessens her
i think rand was a very passionate
person i think she
uh loved her husband enormously
she despised certain people enormously
sure uh
and i don't think that there's anything
wrong wrong she would change her
philosophical position about something
because she disliked somebody i agree
but what i'm saying the amount of
thought she gave to that player
all i'm saying is it is possible
that if someone comes across ideas that
she
had not considered before if she
regarded this person as a bad actor
like all of us she would be less likely
to take them under consideration
sure that's all i'm saying sure and i
think i think other people other people
confronted her with the ideas of anarchy
i don't think rothbard was the only one
correct right charles as well yeah
certainly did and she rejected them and
she rejected them because
she had and and whether you agree with
or not she had a
thought out position about
why you needed to have this particular
structure
in place so that markets and human
freedom could
exist it's just really interesting
because this is the one
time in my view and please correct me if
i'm wrong
where she invokes need as kind of a
basis for political activity
so if let's suppose you want this
federal government whatever you want
you don't want it like it is now like
your version of the government i don't
see
why it's an issue for you for me and lex
to say we're not privy to washington
we're going to do our own thing
and given if we go about our lives not
initiating force
and being productive actors why she
would have an issue with this why would
i care
well you would care because if you're
saying the government has a monopoly on
force between these two oceans
so you can you can do that as long as
you don't violate somebody else's right
sure but what i'm saying is we just
declare ourselves sovereign
we're not going to pay any income taxes
we're going to be peaceable people
we're going to contribute and when rex
and i have disputes
we're going to call joe that's joe rogan
you're never gonna get to meet him but
he's a good guy
i know we're gonna call joe and joe's
gonna resolve it
he's so good at like you know needling
and and getting you off topic that way
it's really
he's really effective at it
i i always say when i debate when i
debate communist
i always say to him you mean lex yeah
maybe lex maybe i should do this comrade
i love you that that if they really
believe indeed
if they really believe in what they
think then they should be advocates for
capitalism because under capitalism
under my system of government capitalist
government right they could go and start
a commune
they can live in coppiness they can live
to each according to
each to each according to his needs
farming according to his ability
all they want and and live their
pathetic miserable lives that way
and and the government would never
intervene because the whole
view of capitalism is freedom is we
leave the way alone
right as long as you're not violating my
rights as long as you're not taking my
property as long as you're not
engaging with so so in that sense yeah
you and lex can form your own thing i
don't believe in compulsory taxes anyway
so you and lex can do your thing never
pay taxes
um do you think as long as you're not
violating the laws
and the laws are very limited right
because they're only there to protect
individualized so long as you're not
violating somebody else's property
rights or inflicting force on anybody
else you're peaceful
you can do what you want you know don't
hit yeah great don't
don't don't have sex with kids right i
will stop immediately
good the rest of us are just plain
checkers and he's playing chess yeah i
mean
i mean a government that protects
individual rights properly is a
government that leaves you alone to live
your life as you see fit even
if you live your life in a way that i
don't approve of that i don't think is
right
i mean that's old point okay then
the only thing you can do is
you know try to enforce arbitrary laws
that you come up with on me of course
absolutely okay great
wouldn't it be wonderful if we lived in
a world where
rights protecting laws are superfluous
but the reality is usually
that somebody violates them whether by
accident
or or intentionally and that you need
some mechanism now if you guys can
resolve that dispute
without getting involved fine but if you
guys
land up not wanting not resolving there
is another authority that will help you
resolve it
yeah so can ask a question under
anarchism
what kind of systems of laws do you
think will emerge do you think we'll
have basically a similar kind of layer
of universal law
to where like let me answer this this is
a great question i know you're going
through this
uh this is often presented as a
criticism of anarchism
and this is actually something i think
iran would agree with as well in other
contexts which is this
one of the reasons communism can't work
central planning can't work and this is
one of mises great innovations
is if i could sit down it's like asking
what would the fashion industry look
like
if the government didn't run it there's
no way for me to know
what the fashion industry is which all
of us are in favor of being free
is literally millions of designers
of seamstresses of uh people who make
the fabric
also references throughout history and
these creative artistic minds putting
things together
and every year and there's no shortage
of clothes
in fact we make so many clothes that we
send them in landfill
sizes to overseas poor countries and you
have people in these desk two countries
wearing like adidas shirts they don't
can't even read english
but because we don't know what to do
with all these clothes that's how
the glory of free enterprise is the
problem is you
probably use this loosely it's
everything comes cheap and over abundant
it's
it like food you know well it doesn't
actually come over abundantly but it's
done properly
sure it's that's fair supply meets
demand sure that's fair but what i'm
saying is like if 150 years ago you said
you know one day we're gonna have an
issue where there's gonna be so much
food and that's it then the kids are too
fat it's just gonna be like i i
too like i had four who are dead in the
crib i wish i mean what kind of fan
what kind of uh paradise is this so
what you would have we have this right
now in certain senses you have the
hassidium
you have sharia you have different comp
you have uh uh
i'm sure in the medical system they have
their own kind of private courts and
court martials is another example this
although obviously that's through the
state
so you would have uh innovation in law
under markets just the same ways you'd
have it and and we have this already
maybe it's not euron doesn't like in
terms of like murder and rape and i can
understand why
but in terms of like business and
interactions he would have no problem
with different arbitration firms
having different rules for like what
kind of evidence is allowed
maybe you only have 60 days to make your
case and so on and so forth
and the market is a process of creative
innovation
and it would be dynamic it would be
changing so what's interesting what's
interesting relating to this is that
one of the ways iran proposed raising
revenue for the government because she
was against uh was
let's say we have a contract we could
just have it arbitrated
without government intervening but if we
wanted to access the courts of the
government
as a final authority we would pay and
that's how governments would raise
some of the funds would be raised that
way so
this definitely a a a value to having
this
innovation and the public space but i
don't believe that
is the case with murder i don't believe
that is the case with violent crime and
and it's funny you bring up sharia
because david friedman when he gives
when he gives uh wait i gotta ask you to
clarify i'm not trying to interrupt you
you're talking about with murder i mean
you would agree i think just to clarify
for the audience
that there is room for innovation and
murder because there's things like
manslaughter there's murder juan murder
too yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i think i don't think it
happens at a at a market level i don't
think there's a market innovation
for murder somebody has to figure out
what those standards are and they will
evolve
as we gain right now but we're all
agreement that the the word murder means
very different things oh absolutely and
and if circumstances matter and
and and what are your standards of proof
standards of evidence
all of that there has to be consequences
too all of that there has to be a
standard and that's
that's what the that's what i think the
proper government provides
um but uh so david friedman uses in in
some of his talks about private law he
uses
he he uses uh sharia law in somalia as
an example look
legal legal systems they've all
privately independent
yeah authoritarian ones ones that don't
respect the rights of women at all
are you married uh no no but we all want
to have sex with our mother as voyage
would say
oh my god can we make that a clip yep
where the hell did that come from
that's much better than what i was just
saying about the kids i appreciate it
okay so we went in a voluntary way
although sometimes for year on and
sometimes for michael it
felt involuntary but uh i
we all got the big guns so uh how do we
land
this at the beginning clearly there's a
disagreement about
uh anarchism here i think we're in agree
i think there's a big agreement
because if jaron was saying that if i
want to have my voluntary stupid thing
with you
and his government is not going to tax
me and it's not going to
insinuate itself unless we're murdering
each other something like that i'm okay
with that
so so if you take if you take the
example of sharia law which was
mentioned earlier
so if you impo if you have a little
community within this
within my world right that that imposes
sharia law
um if
it starts mutilating little girls sure
then that then you impose your low on it
right you impose the law on it because
it's an issue protecting individual
rights
if they want to treat women if women
have to cover up
and the women are okay with that that's
fine if the woman wants to leave
but is not allowed to leave that's where
my government would step in
and and and allow you know
prevent them from using force against
her and that's it
right okay now i i think it's more
complicated than that
right because i think there are complex
issue property rights often
where it's not going to be easy for you
guys to resolve and
and particularly if you interact with
people outside of your community
but but uh but yeah i you know that's
my view is government is there to
protect individual rights that's it
otherwise leave you alone
you